hello, how are you, tirso zermeño, the
consul general of el salvador greets you here in
las vegas, for us it is very
exciting to announce our first
mobile vaccination day this coming
saturday from 8 in the morning to
4 in the afternoon thanks to you who have
scheduled to  receive this vaccine here
at the consulate, but more
importantly, it is still important to invite the entire
community, all of you, to
participate and be part of
this community health through
vaccination, the vaccination is free, it is
effective, it is important that all of you
attend  to the different places that are
open to receive that vaccine, that
you be part of this solution to the
pandemic that we be the ones that
bring the solution to this city,
that this state is open again that
we return to normality that we do not
remember the pain it causes
and others who have lost a family member
that we be part of normality
again
one says all this is part is in
our hands  bring health
back to our families
thank you be aware of
vaccination it is our responsibility it is
an act of love vaccines